En las últimas décadas ha sido algo muy
normal considerar al inquilino de La Casa
Blanca, al Presidente de los Estados Unidos,
como la persona más poderosa del planeta.
Sin embargo, amigos, las cosas pueden estar
cambiando… o, incluso, pueden haber cambiado
ya.
¿Conocéis al Presidente chino? Sí, desde
luego que sí, aquí en VisualPolitik, hemos
hablado ya alguna que otra vez de él.
Pues bien, fijaos, el mismísimo Donald Trump,
en declaraciones recogidas por el Washington
Post, ha calificado a este presidente chino,
a Xi Jinping, como el líder más poderoso
que China ha tenido en el último siglo…
lo que es tanto como decir que Xi Jinping
es el líder chino más poderoso de todos
los tiempos.
Tanto que cada vez más analistas se preguntan
si no estaremos ya ante el líder político
más poderoso del mundo.
Sí, es verdad.
Tanto la economía de China como su ejército
siguen estando en un segundo nivel si lo comparamos
con Estados Unidos… pero, mientras que Trump
parece perder, minuto a minuto, influencia
en el mundo y también dentro de casa, Xi
Jinping sigue el camino opuesto.
[[ Un momento, ¿qué EEUU con Trump pierde
influencia?... Pero si últimamente Donald
quiere ser el amigo de todos… ¿habéis
visto este tweet tan tierno?
¿Por qué Kim Jong-un me insultaría llamándome
viejo cuando yo nunca le llamaría bajo y
gordo? Oh, bueno, trato tanto de ser su amigo,
¡y quizá algún día eso ocurra!
Sí… definitivamente no me extraña que
Estados Unidos esté perdiendo influencia
en el mundo… En pocos meses Trump ha pasado
de la guerra nuclear… a la pelea de patio
de colegio.]]
En fin, en serio. El caso es que aunque Xi
Jinping no es el Presidente de la primera
potencia del mundo, controla férreamente
la dirección de China, uno de los motores
económicos más importantes del planeta.
Y desde luego, amigos, Trump, ha sido para
Pekín, como decirlo...algo así como un Gran
Premio de la Lotería. Atentos:
(El proteccionismo, el nacionalismo y los
errores de Donald Trump le han permitido a
Xi Jinping, el Presidente de China, la mayor
dictadura del mundo, presentar su candidatura
a una especie de liderazgo político mundial.
En enero de 2017, en el Foro de Davos, Xi
Jinping prometió que China se convertiría,
ni más ni menos, que en el campeón de la
globalización, el libre comercio, e, incluso,
la lucha contra el cambio climático. De esta
forma Pekín aspira a quedarse con el terreno
que está perdiendo Washington en la política
internacional.)
Lo que se olvidó fue hablar de libertad y
tal… pero…
¿Qué pasó en el último Congreso del Partido
Comunista Chino? ¿Cuánto poder tiene Xi
Jinping? ¿Qué es lo que quiere? Bien, vamos
a verlo, pero antes echemos un vistazo a China.
LA NUEVA CHINA
¿Pensais que China sigue siendo ese país
donde las personas malviven, deslomándose
a trabajar por salarios miserables? Pues…
lo siento, pero estáis algo equivocados.
En 2018, se cumple el 40 aniversario de la
política de reforma y apertura de China.
Y en este tiempo el país ha cambiado mucho.
China ya no es un país de ingresos bajos,
sino uno de ingresos medios.
De hecho, teniendo en cuenta la diferencia
de precios, esto es lo que se denomina paridad
de poder adquisitivo, su PIB per cápita viene
a ser de unos 16.000$, algo superior al de
Colombia o Brasil, por ejemplo.
Además su economía ha cambiado, y hoy los
servicios son ya la actividad más importante.
(Hablamos, por ejemplo, del comercio electrónico,
un sector en el está poder delante de Europa
e incluso de Estados Unidos. China representa
ni más ni menos que el 40% de todas las transacciones
en el mundo.
Lo mismo podemos decir de los pagos móviles,
tan popularizados en este país, que su mercado
alcanzó en 2016 los 5,5 billones de dólares.
50 veces más que en Estados Unidos.)
No está mal, ¿Verdad?
El crecimiento ha sido de tal magnitud que
tan solo en los últimos 6 años, el consumo
privado de los chinos ha crecido en 2,5 billones
de dólares, una cifra equivalente, atentos,
a todo el PIB de la India.
Por todo esto, amigos, no es extraño que
cuando visitamos alguna de las grandes ciudades
chinas nos encontremos con un país repleto
de rascacielos, multimillonarios y trenes
de alta velocidad.
Pero, esperad un momento.
Sí, es verdad, en China sigue pobreza y,
en general, hay una gran diferencia entre
las ciudades y las zonas rurales que siguen
siendo pobres, muy pobres.
(43 millones de personas, casi la población
de toda España, siguen viviendo en una situación
de extrema pobreza con menos de 1$ al día.
Y no solo eso, cerca del 40% de los chinos,
aunque mucho mejor que hace décadas, siguen
viviendo en un nivel económico bastante bajo).
Pero como os decía las cosas están cambiando
muy rápido, y ya no podemos pensar en China
de la misma forma que lo hacíamos hace 20,
10 o incluso 5 años.
Por cierto… precisamente en relación a
la pobreza… algo bastante curioso, ¿sabéis
cómo enfoca el gobierno chino la lucha contra
la pobreza?
Pues, una de sus principales estrategias pasa
por conseguir que en las comunidades más
pobres se creen nuevas empresas y cooperativas.
Tan solo a este fin el gobierno lleva concedidos,
ojo, casi 400.000 millones de dólares en
pequeños préstamos que permiten que muchas
personas se puedan poner en marcha.
Y, ojo, no se trata solo de un enfoque de
dinero, también en cierto modo cultural.
“Los noticiarios nocturnos están llenos
de historias sobre las comunidades renovadas
y los habitantes de estos sitios que se han
convertido en empresarios y que llenan de
halagos a Xi y al gobierno”. Javier C. Hernández,
corresponsal en China del New York Times.
Sí, lo se… Xi Jiping y prácticamente todos
los jerarcas del país hablan mucho de “socialismo
al estilo chino”...
En realidad no es más que una fórmula para
hablar de una especie de modelo capitalista
encerrado en una dictadura.
Porque amigos, China no es una dictadura ideológica…
ni socialista, ni comunista… es simplemente
una dictadura.
Pero bien, dicho esto… hablemos de Xi Jinping,
la persona que dirige con un poder prácticamente
total, esta nueva China.
XI JINPING, EL LIDER
Nacido en 1953, Xi Jinping, amigos, es un
tipo curioso. Por un lado, es probablemente
el líder chino que más contacto ha tenido
con Occidente.
Su hija, sin ir más lejos, estudió en Harvard,
una hermana suya vive en Canadá y él mismo,
conoce bien, lo ha visitado muchas veces,
Estados Unidos. De hecho, en 2012 cuando visitó
Estados Unidos en calidad de vicepresidente
de China, hizo una parada un tanto peculiar:
fue a visitar Iowa. “Iowa, ¿por qué Iowa?
le preguntó el mismísimo Obama”. Pues
el caso es que en 1985 cuando Xi Jinping era
joven secretario del partido en un condado
de China, hizo un viaje a Iowa con el fin
de investigar temas relacionados con la agricultura.
En Así que en 2012 fue a ver a la familia
con la que se quedó por aquel entonces y
les llevó regalos, ¿vaya historia, verdad?
Además el lado ‘yankee’ del presidente
Xi no queda ahí, también es bien conocido
que le encantan las películas belicas de
Hollywood. Sí, películas como Salvar Soldado
Ryan.
Tal cual como escucháis.
(Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo, desde que se
convirtió en la máxima autoridad de China
hace 5 años, su gobierno se ha caracterizado,
por ser el más censor y represor, en años…
No tenemos más que fijarnos en la última
ley de ciberseguridad, que busca controlar
aún más Internet en China restringiendo
el anonimato, hasta tal punto que por ejemplo
obliga a que en las redes sociales todas las
cuentas estén respaldadas por un ciudada
real perfectamente identificado.)
Además, todo ello ha estado acompañado por
una política de culto al líder, también,
inédita en mucho tiempo.
Sí, podemos decir que los servicios de propaganda
han trabajado a destajo.
Pero bueno… nada que pueda sorprendernos
¿Verdad?
Bien, el caso es que en estos 5 años, Xi
Jinping ha hecho muchos cambios en China…
empezando por la reforma del ejército o por
una política exterior particularmente activa.
Lo hemos visto aquí, en VisualPolitik, Xi
Jinping ha puesto los recursos nacionales
al servicio de la política exterior.
Ahí está por ejemplo… el macroproyecto
de la Nueva Ruta de la Seda, que planea invertir
cientos de miles de millones de dólares en
un montón de países.
Pero con todo su mayor apuesta, ha sido, sin
duda, la lucha contra la corrupción.
(En estos años el régimen chino ha sancionado
a más 1 millón y medio de miembros del Partido
Comunista y procesado a casi 300.000; incluyendo
a 43 miembros del Cómite Central.
También. en el marco de esta lucha contra
la corrupción, 13.000 oficiales del ejército
han sido despedidos y más de 50 generales
encarcelados.)
Claro que… no todo el mundo ve esta batalla
como algo tan limpio y honesto:
“Es una selectiva campaña anticorrupción.
Su objetivo es una protección selectiva de
la corrupción. Cuando purgas a algunos cargos
corruptos, estás protegiendo al resto. Proteges
el sistema corrupto, y proteges a corruptos
que te apoyan” - Bao Tong, activista chino
Sí, Xi Jinping ha “depurado” sobre todo
a sus rivales políticos ¿Casualidad?¿Coincidencia?
Bueno, desde luego, lo que está claro es
que en estos cinco años Xi Jinping ha ganado
mucho poder.
Esto, amigos, es algo que se ha visto, perfectamente,
en el último Congreso del Partido Comunista
de China, el evento político más importante
de este país y que se celebra cada cinco
años. Atentos.
EL XIX CONGRESO
Este decimonoveno Congreso del Partido Comunista
Chino, celebrado entre los días 18 y 24 de
Octubre de 2017, fue bastante particular,
empezando porque tal vez ha sido el Congreso
más austero que el Partido Comunista Chino
ha celebrado en muchos, muchísimos años
Sí, en esta ocasión se eliminaron algunas
comodidades, ¿Queréis algún ejemplo?
Pues, entre otras cosas - ojo, esto va en
serio, no es broma - se suprimió la barra
libre de langostinos y también los servicios
de peluquería, tratamiento facial y sastrería
que se ofrecían gratis a los participantes
y que eran ya casi una tradición.
Pero por encima de todo, este ha sido el Congreso
en el que Xi Jinping ha sido elevado a los
altares, algo que como os podéis imaginar
en China quiere decir ser puesto al nivel,
casi, de Mao Zedong.
“Hace cinco años predije que Xi sería
el líder más poderoso de China desde Deng
Xiaoping. Me equivoqué. Se ha convertido
en el líder más poderoso desde Mao Zedong”.
Kevin Rudd, Exprimer Ministro de Australia.
Veréis, en este Congreso se ha decidido que
el llamado “pensamiento de Xi Jinping”
sea incluido en la Constitución del Partido
Comunista.
Esto puede parecernos un poco raro, pero lo
que viene a significar es que Xi Jinping ya
no es un líder más, es el líder con mayúsculas,
el líder cuya palabra forma la propia ideología
del partido.
“La inclusión de su pensamiento significa
que Xi es intocable. Si lo cuestionas, estás
cuestionando al partido y no quieres tener
al partido en contra”. Bill Bishop, editor
de Sinocism.
Hasta ahora solo Mao Zedong había recibido
semejante honor en vida.
Pero ahí no acaba todo.
Actualmente el mandato de un presidente está
limitado a 10 años, de tal forma que este
comienza sería el último mandato de Xi Jinping…
pero… un momento… porque en esta ocasión
no se ha contemplado ningún sucesor así
que todo a punta a que Xi Jinping aspirara,
por lo menos, a un tercer mandato.
“Las universidades chinas luchas por abrir
centros para estudiar el pensamiento del presidente
Xi Jinping”
Pero bueno, más allá del líder chino, este
Congreso ha servido para marcar las 3 grandes
prioridades del gobierno chino en los próximos
años:
1º la economía, combatir la pobreza y abrirse
más al mundo; 2º Poner en marcha una política
exterior aún más fuerte y 3º Empezar a
preocuparse del Medio AMbiente.
Y bueno aunque he dicho 3 prioridades hay
una 4º que ha quedado muy clara: consolidar
el poder del Partido Comunista. Porque, amigos,
hay dos cosas que han quedado muy claras:
Por una lado, que tendremos Xi Jinping y Partido
Comunista en CHina por mucho tiempo; por otro
que China reclama su papel como superpotencia.
Acostumbremonos a tener en cuenta a Pekín.
En fín, ahora turno para ti ¿Quién consideras
que va a dejar primero el poder, XI Jinping
o Vladimir Putin?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like, y
no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.